hello everyone and welcome to a video
where it will be revealed how you
yourself can play against alireza now
for those of you who are only interested
in that bit of information it will be in
the timestamps below so you can just
click on that but I urge you to check
out this game I've prepared a very nice
one and
um then we're gonna get how you can plug
and install iteza and some of the
updates that we've done on our app uh
now this is a game from the iron float
open it was played on the 29th of
February in 2017 and as you can see
alireza was not the 2800 monster he is
today he was rated 24.65 so he is the
underdog in this fight and he is
fighting against Matthias bluebound who
was at the time uh fifth rated Junior in
in the world with the with a rating of
26.32 so let's see this incredible game
and then we are going to discuss the
specifics of how you can play against
alireza now alireza had the white pieces
and he opened with Ponte E4 we have Pawn
to C6 and goes for the karokan defense
with d for D5 and alireza goes for the
advanced variation Ponte E5 with Bishop
to F5 and now okay you could go for the
uh some crazy stuff with G4 the the
bayonet attack but algresa goes for the
nice calm short variation Knight F3 Pawn
to E6 and now uh nowadays Bishop to E2
uh is uh pretty much uh uh a move that
everyone plays but in the game alireza
played C3 it's actually the fourth most
popular continuation and um as I was
able to learn uh only Russians play it
uh so it's sort of uh on the absolute
highest level Russians play it like
Nippon now she plays the grisho plays it
fedossa plays it and alireza played it
in this game okay uh C3 uh we have
Knights the E7 and Knight to D7 is the
move that is standard against Pawn to C3
but after Knight E7 there are only a
handful of games in the database with
this position so Bishop to E2 Knights to
G6 and now Pawn to h4a this is all right
let's just kick away that night from
such a silly Square Mathias says Nope
plays H5 but by playing H5 he also
allowed Knight to G5 now you can never
play H6 again once you've played H5 and
also the pawn on H5 is sort of hanging
so on the F6 you have to challenge the
Knight with e captures and F6 G captures
and now Knight back to H3 and here King
to D7 obviously uh this is a still still
a known line and this has been played
before and otherwise you wouldn't just
be walking around with your king like
that and while you could capture the H5
Pawn the H4 Pawn is also hanging so all
it is a place Knight F4 now the pawn is
defended Knight captures an F4 Bishop
captures and now Queen to E8 now the
queen and the Rook are guarding the H5
pawn and there is a game where Knight
the D2 was played but alireza plays Pawn
to C4 and it is now as of move 13 that
this position has never been reached
again
uh Matthias the characters in C4 we have
Bishop characters and now Queen to G6
now uh putting pressure on the G2 Pawn
also if you move the queen to a silly
Square then you blunder the Knight on B1
uh but alireza ignores all of that and
just plays Queen to B3 and now okay the
Knight is hanging the G2 Pawn can be
captured what's the idea here well the
idea here okay if Bishop captures and B1
that's just terrible that loses um if
Bishop captures on B1 and then you can
just play Queen captures on B7 check and
it's game over but the really fun stuff
happens if Queen captures and G2 is
played and The Rook on H1 is now being
threatened you're still gonna capture on
B7 with check and after King to d8 now
okay you can't capture because uh Queen
characters and H1 also comes with check
so we're gonna play Rook to F1 and now
Queen to E4 with check Bishop to E3 is
now the bishop is hanging Bishop E3 and
now C5 you defend your Rook like this
and once everything gets traded off
let's say captures captures a knight to
C3 attacks the bishop you don't really
have good moves with black here because
the D file will open up the bishop is
hanging also these exponent is saying so
you can avoid two of the three threads
but not the third one not just be campus
Rook 81 check is coming uh alireza would
be up upon and it would be a past C Pawn
so this would be very very good for
alireza so the only move here for
Matthias is Pawn to B5 which he played
uh and now after this we have simply
castles all it is it says of course the
bishop cannot be captured the bishop to
a queen B7 check is still very very much
deadly so Rook G8 Matthias uh counters
by going for a checkmating threat of
Queen captures and G2 and all it is a
defense with Pawn to G3 now comes Queen
to G4 Queen to G4 with some nasty ideas
of just checkmating the white king but
also with a with a simple Queen captures
on F4 a threat as the g-pawn cannot move
so while it is a plays a very tricky
Rook to E1 move now uh invites uh all
sorts of moves but Queen captures on F4
is now met with Bishop captures and E6
with check and course you're not going
to capture you're going to move the king
but now comes the bishop captures on F5
and you win back your material and you
you cannot capture back otherwise you're
going to lose the rook and G8 as well
The Rook G7 Bishop B4 and the game
continues with um black just having a
terrible King and C7 uh how you should
continue this is uh well not something
that anyone would think of it's Ponte A5
and now after Pawn to A4 you have to
play Bishop to B4 you attack The Rook
here and now a captures on B5 uh Bishop
captures an E1 B captures and C6 check
and now you cannot even capture this you
have to go back and with King the E8
black would have a well a a a fine game
uh you want some material your king is
in a pretty bad shape but uh with
objectively best play Black should be
better here but okay after rookie one uh
Bishop to B4 was played right away by
Matthias and now that is a uh has the
idea of course is that if Queen captures
now you can capture the a bishop but
alireza went for a win for Bishop
captures and E6 check the bishop
captures now comes with Rook captures
and now Queen capture so he sacrifices
The Exchange Queen captures on B4 and
now Knight day six and you have to be
really quick about it because you're
also not um great in development so 96
attacks the queen queen to D2 and now
Rook 8 to E8 again in control of the E
file while it is a continuous
development Knight to C3 prepares D5 and
the Matthias stops it with Knight to C7
but yeah still plays it pawn to D5 you
could also consider Pawn to B4 but you
could consider that in any position so
D5 Knight captures and D5 Knight
captures Queen captures and not just
Queen to C2 and now if you look at the
position uh Five Pawns each but Matthias
is just up up the exchange so the only
thing alireza has going for him is the
weak position of the black king So King
the C8 Matthias trying to improve it a
little bit Rook to D1 and here you have
to play Queen E4 Queen to E4 or queen to
C4 batteries Queen to E4 and you are
still playing this game but after Queen
the F3 the position is now completely
winning for alireza but it's really not
easy to see why so feel free to pause
the video and win the game for alireza
while I give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on finding this uh
crazy line and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show the movies Queen
to F5 would check it's the first movie
thought of of course so it's not the
difficult one what's difficult is what
comes after this King to B7 uh and now
Rook to D7 with check and now of course
you cannot go to King to B6 because
sorry you cannot go uh King to B6 yeah
because Bishop to C7 check just blunders
the queen on F3 so you cannot touch the
dark squares you have to go to A8 or on
A6 but uh whatever you play the all it
is the next move is is the same as he
has played King day eight and now
alireza just played The Rook captures on
A7 with check the point being now
matthias's King is being forced to a
dark Square which means there will be
discoveries on the black queen that's
why the queen is weak and F3 it's simply
undefended ah so King captures an A6 on
A7 and now Bishop to B8 with check King
captures and alireza wins The Black
Queen with Queen captures on F3 but it's
still two Rooks against the queen
alireza is up a pawn but the problem is
he's attacking the C6 spawn and the H5
Pawn so he's gonna win uh one of them
and it's not great if you if you give up
C6 then uh you're just gonna be checked
to Infinity you're gonna lose both of
the pawns and then the A and B pawns are
Marching forward and if you defend the
C6 Pawn then you lose this Pawn you
create a an H Pawn and that's also
trouble so Matthias had to choose uh
between two of the Lesser evils he
defended the C6 spawn now Queen
characters on H5 we have Rook G to E8
doubling up on the E file now Queen to
F7 just uh being annoying here and
preparing to push the H Pawn rotate the
E7 kicking away the queen queen to G6
with King to B7 now comes Pawn to H5 we
have King to B6 and you can't uh play H6
right away if you play H6 then F5 is
very strong but alireza finds a way he
plays Pawn to G4 and okay we have pawned
the C5 and Matthias trying to create
some counter play here maybe if he can
get three moves then he will also get a
past Pawn but now alireza finds H6 and
now the problem is there is no way to
counter it H7 is coming Matthias did
play F F5 but now there comes something
that I always mention in games uh yes
you have a queen and it's a great
Advantage having a queen but sometimes
you have to trade that Advantage for a
different uh kind of advantage and
that's exactly what all it is that does
here he plays G captures on F5 he gives
back the queen and you can't capture the
queen and you cannot not capture the
queen if you just move back then H7 is
completely winning so Matthias had to
capture the queen F captures and G6 two
connected pass pawns on the sixth rank
are stronger than a rook of course Rook
to E6 was played hoping to get some
check uh checking action here but just
G7 we have Rook to G6 check all it is a
play King to F1 and he was in this
position on a move uh 42 that Matthias
bluebomb resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here whatever
black plays doesn't really matter if you
capture an H6 then all it is a promotes
a pawn if you push upon then H7 and and
the pawns are unstoppable you can
capture one of them but the other one
will still Queen and of course a queen
beats a rook so incredible game and I
was very sad to see that I still haven't
shown this game on the channel but that
also made me very happy because that
meant I get to show it today so you know
you you win however you play it I guess
uh now that we've enjoyed this
brilliancy of the young galireza from
2017. let's um uh let's head straight to
the news so the way you guys can play
against alireza if uh is if you download
our improve app now uh We've published
it some two months ago I believe maybe a
month and a half ago and uh already I I
don't know the exact number over I I
know that over 10 000 people have
downloaded it and are are trying it out
uh some are enjoying it very much and
you uh guys are also able to do that now
the first link in the description below
is a link where you can download the app
and get into it now the way you get
for the moment we are we are thinking of
uh 20 of the best improvers so uh you
get raining or not raining you get
points when you improve when you finish
an action item and then you climb up the
leaderboard so these are the current
leaders the top 10 uh Emmy uh wib smog
nap mark Patrick the Prague Lube cool
blue Sam uh Michelle 13 Sierra Chuck H
and Damas so those are the top 10 and
the top 20 people in our app will get a
chance to play against alireza firuja on
the 20th of October uh he will be uh
holding a simultaneous exhibition on
leeches and he will be joining me for a
live stream uh we're gonna go through
the games and he will be also
commentating on your games uh if uh you
know if it's not going to be too hard
for him to play against you guys and now
uh the those who are eligible to enter
this simultaneous exhibition are those
who are full-time members of the improve
app that means that those who are who
have access to the full lab the full app
is 3.99 a month and you get all sorts of
perks if you become a full-time member
and playing galireza is only only the
the first of the great events that we
are planning to create now also I wanted
to mention that uh we've done some
improvements on the app uh uh some of
you had problems uh logging into uh as a
some countries had problems logging into
the app so we fixed that and also a lot
of you have requested that you would
prefer logging in via email then via uh
uh a phone number so that will be
implemented uh very soon as I as I
understand it and also we've included
some new action items over 100 action
items has been included to help you uh
improve further uh so that's uh that's
regarding that and uh also I wanted to
mention that we would very much we would
very much enjoy if you left us a review
on the Apple Store and and on the and on
the Google Play Store and further
incentivize you in doing that we are
offering three uh one-year subscriptions
to the improve app so whoever uh whoever
helps us on the on the App Store it
doesn't have to be a positive comment it
can be also a negative comment or a
neutral comment we just need comments uh
we'll go into the roster to win a a free
one-year subscription and uh when you
comment on the uh on the app store or on
the Google Play Store uh just copy paste
your comment in the description in the
comments of this video on YouTube so as
we are going to pull the winners from
the YouTube video uh so yeah so uh if
you guys are already on the app that's
great that means you are already
eligible to play all it is if there will
be too many people uh improving and it
will be a really really close call on
the top 20. we will include five more
and we will add them on random so we're
gonna do the top 20 and then five people
in random so everyone that really gets a
chance to to face alireza
the time format is still being decided
but probably you guys will get half an
hour and alireza will get a little bit
more as he will have to play against 20
people so he will also have to spend
time switching uh through the boards but
yeah it's a great opportunity for you to
face one of the uh greatest players of
Chess today
while he also comments on your game live
uh so I don't know that's that's pretty
uh pretty incredible so remember it's
only for
um for users who have the full version
of the app so if you if you want to get
in on the action uh you know the sooner
the better as you will be able to
accumulate points uh uh much much much
faster and even if you are a free user
of the app you can still accumulate
points only they will not count for uh
who is uh in the top 20. so as usual I
probably have forgotten to mention
something very important but if I you
know remember it I will also mention it
in the comments of this video probably
pin my comments so yeah you guys have a
a better understanding of everything
that's happening if you have any
questions also do ask I will answer it
in the in the comments section but yeah
that's pretty much it 20th of October
that will be the uh simultaneous
exhibition you guys have a chance to
play holidays uh let's uh let's have a
let's have a great time and hope that
this is only the first of many great
events um uh in collaboration with the
improve app uh so yeah that's the video
and a little bit of extra info on the on
the app and what we are doing hope you
enjoyed that I would like to thank
Amanda Oliver the most beautiful girl in
the world the Duncan wine called
egbertian olive oil and Adam Decker the
loneliest guy in the world for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check to my previous videos here
thank you all for watching and I will
see you soon continuing to check up on
you wonderful suggestions and whatever
else happens in the Chess World so thank
you all I will see you soon and have an
excellent rest of your day